[Música]
se nós falarmos para vocês que é
possível viver um novo mundo
nós acreditamos novo mundo no mundo mais
harmonioso mais pacífico e nós
acreditamos através de uma ativação de
uma rede através da união que é possível
a gente criar esse novo mundo
nós tivemos um grande sonho e através
desse sonho
nós nos encontramos a partir de uma
intenção muito profunda de transformar o
mundo a partir da nossa própria
transformação
a gente resolveu ativar uma rede ativa
uma rede que tinha assim como nós esse
propósito de construir um mundo mais
pacífico ea partir disso então a gente
através desse sonho que a gente é
cocriou juntas a gente foi ativando
outras pessoas e outras redes que foram
na verdade trazendo essa intenção desse
mundo transformador que a gente tanto
quer e que começa do lado de dentro ea
partir disso o que a gente trouxe como
intenção que a gente queria justamente
trazer esse novo olhar para o mundo de
que a gente tá tão separado tão
desconectados da nossa própria essência
ea gente é a natureza ea gente está
desconectado dela ea gente está a dessa
forma desconectada também dos outros ea
partir disso a gente resolveu criar um
evento e ativar uma rede a rede pela paz
neste momento que a gente resolveu
ativar essa rede a gente se deparou com
muitos desafios como fazer isso com que
pessoas com vontade que forma fazer e
nós pensamos em criar um evento
e aí o grande desafio foi e agora nós
com que recursos nós vamos fazer esse
evento com que pessoas nós vamos contar
para poder construir isso e mas foi algo
mágico porque a partir da intenção que
nós tivemos muitas outras então outras
pessoas organizações e empresas foram se
colando eles foram chegando
chegaram os facilitadores de dentro da
equipe dentro do brasil e de fora foram
chegando os recursos
partiu de um paradigma de escassez onde
não era possível fazer um paradigma de
abundância
a gente começou a se conectar com os
valores da natureza que o que a gente
chama de roda da terra que é onde tudo
tem fluxo onde tudo está conectado é
onde a gente pode a partir da união
começar a transformar nossa realidade
a gente começou a criar algo mas não
porque a eles que estou a silvia o halo
a gente começou a criar porque havia uma
intenção em tensão nesse mundo mais
pacífico se unindo de todas as pessoas
que foi mágico ea partir dessa magia é
que tudo foi acontecendo e para isso
obviamente a gente precisou tem muitos
atributos dentre eles muita confiança
muita coragem como a nossa colega acabou
dizendo anterior aqui a gente teve que
trazer essa coragem de dentro do nosso
coração né pra que a gente pudesse
acreditar que era possível diante de
recursos financeiros 10
a gente não tinha nada de recurso para
um grande evento que traía todas essa
consciência e unindo os setores da
sociedade
então a gente trouxe esse olhar de está
a atrasar sendo o enfoque da educação só
que uma educação consciente
transformadora que acontece não só na
escola mas como nas empresas nas
famílias na no setor público então
unindo aquilo que nos une
porque muitas vezes a gente está tão
separado na e não sabe há tanta coisa
linda que já acontece é vocês hoje
ouviram nem falar que também que o novo
ainda possível e que a gente pode tá
olhando e se esse novo mundo né ea
partir disso há as coisas foram
acontecendo muito magicamente mas também
com muito trabalho
não é preciso ter o atributo muito forte
da vontade porque sem a vontade a gente
não teria dado os passos seguintes né e
um mais lindo desse processo todo foi
porque a gente está falando no mundo
pacífico então a gente estava
trabalhando numa equipe com mais de 30
voluntários mais de 20 artistas é muita
gente engajada nessa rede e com luan
mostro isso de uma forma harmônica é uma
rede onde todas as pessoas podem dar o
melhor de si onde há onde elas podem ser
onde elas são nutridas onde elas são
acolhidas onde elas são apoiadas e como
criar esse ambiente então a gente
começou a ver que esse mundo pacífico
que a gente está buscando a partir da
ativação de uma rede a partir do do que
a gente estava buscando lá fora estava
interno estava com a gente estava a
partir das nossas relações de como a
gente estava construindo isso de como a
gente estava se relacionando ea gente
começou a ver sim é possível nas
relações com todos os apoiadores onde
cada um deu o melhor de si e muita gente
deu um evento o curso desse evento a 150
mil reais ea gente viabilizou ele com 26
mil reais
o restante todo o valor era convertido à
medida que a gente ia é captando apoios
não informe de recurso financeiro isso é
tudo sendo convertido em bolsas para que
os educadores das redes municipais que
não tinha condições de estar lá
estivessem e se criou um ambiente de
abundância tão grande tão poderoso e
nosso evento aconteceu há uma semana
atrás e foi um encontro realmente lindo
e foi transformador e ele foi
transformador desde o primeiro momento
quando a gente se encontrou
quando a gente encontrou todas essas
pessoas
até esse momento que a gente está aqui
passando pra você a gente é possível a
gente não está separado
a gente está junto a gente só se
esqueceu a gente diz conector e à medida
que a gente começa a se conectar a gente
vê a potência que surge desse encontro
que é algo maravilhoso é mágico mesmo é
e também assim a foi um grande exercício
para a rede porque aquilo que a gente
queria traduzir no evento a gente tinha
os nossos desafios na porque trabalhar
em prol de um propósito muita gente às
vezes tem os desafios que surgem os
medos que aparecem ea partir dessa
intenção forte a gente foi se apoiando
se no triângulo se acolhendo e fazendo
as coisas acontecer é eu quero contar
uma história pra vocês que aconteceu
numa das subidas para serra que esse
evento foi em canela
o que a gente precisava arranjar a gente
resolveu fazer um
centro de feiras é enorme não tinha
nenhuma estrutura a não ser o espaço não
é claro mas não tinham cadeiras não
tinha som palco enfim tinha toda uma
estrutura que precisava ser montada e
naquela naquele dia a gente subiu
intencionando muito forte de que a gente
precisava os móveis a gente já tinha
conseguido vários outros itens e agent
of z tomar papelaria ea gente precisava
dentro dessa papelaria também de papéis
para poder votar nas bolsas que nem
vocês receberam hoje é que isso aqui a
gente estava fazendo um grande exercício
de largar as atenções não define para as
pessoas de que forma elas podiam apoiar
existe um apoio financeiro e também que
elas poderiam fazer
existiam os recursos que elas poderiam
fazer mas a gente falava sobre o
propósito do evento se ressoava se
tocava na pessoa né naquela instituição
mas que também não era uma instituição
era uma pessoa ali na nossa frente nessa
ela tinha esse propósito também ea gente
abrir então as possibilidades de como
ela podia apoiar e nesse momento que a
gente na pressuposto que poderia sair de
lá com um papel mas não não largou essa
intenção magoar o roberto é ela chega e
diz pra nós olha eu gostaria muito de
apoiar é maravilhoso evento a gente
precisa realmente se unir a educação ela
precisa ser propagada nesse âmbito mas
da consciência mas eu não vou poder
apoiar com 11 financeiramente mas se
você se interessarem eu tenho uma loja
de locação de imóveis interessa pra você
a gente olhou viu out demais né porque é
isso gente tudo foi assim sabe as coisas
foram acontecendo num fluxo de uma
fluidez muito linda que a gente acredita
muito nesse fluxo sem do universo das
intenções de quando a gente está
alinhado num propósito né é que as
coisas podem acontecer de forma
maravilhosa
enfim foi muito lindo a gente trouxe a
gente de são paulo também anda de
portugal da bolívia tudo com esse olhar
de educação consciente transformadora
trouxe
muitas vivências porque a gente precisa
viver a gente precisa sentir que precisa
resgatar o o o sentir na a gente traz
muito o âmbito da cabeça do coletivo só
a gente não é só o cognitivo né
a gente tem todas as nossas dimensões do
ser que a gente precisa usar isso a
gente precisa despertar esse novo olhar
então isso nos trouxe e é muito forte
muito significativo para a gente ea
gente gostaria de contar pra vocês a
gente não está sozinho a gente está
conectado às vezes a gente só não achou
ainda e eu acho que esse encontro aqui
ele é um encontro para promover essas
conexões e cada vez a gente está mais
perto quando a intenção é pura e ela ela
vem do coração ela vai encontrar outra
conexão ela vai encontrar outra intenção
ressoando isso é verdadeira a gente
viveu isso e quando a gente está falando
de construir este mundo mais pacífico
que eu acho que é algo que permeia né a
gente acredita que isso tá no coração de
cada ser humano embora às vezes a gente
na roda viva da vida a gente no piloto
automático a gente esqueça
mas essa centelha divina lá ela tá
apagadinha e daqui a pouco a tua própria
luz ela vai ajudar o outro sem idéia
dele e assim a gente vai aprendendo um
do outro mundo outra ea gente vai se
conectando é possível ele é possível
começando a partir desse quer ver o
mundo limpo vai a calçada da casa
o mundo vai estar limpo sabe fique em
paz contigo essa parcela vai-vai
perseguindo então a gente teve uma
experiência linda de conseguir reunir
vários setores da sociedade a partir da
ativação a gente une o setor público a
gente teve na abertura do evento o
secretário de educação a gente teve
empresários famílias crianças de mão
dadas dançando em nome do mundo mais
pacífico
é esse o recado é que a gente gostaria
de deixar para você essa não se sintam
sozinhos quando você estiver em um sonho
porque a partir dessa intenção é
possível e se esse sonho for um mundo
mais pacífico
com certeza eu acho que é a
é isso a gente só senhor com certeza e
outra coisa interessante assim no evento
que nem a silva estava colocando né
a gente quebrou alguns protocolos no
evento é porque a gente tem que pensar
de que forma a gente faz as coisas e por
que né então que nem ela falou ali eu
tava todo mundo criança mãe pai e
secretário não é todos os setores da
sociedade juntos na horizontal todo
mundo olhava olho dançando junto de mãos
dadas trazendo essa intenção não que não
não tenho que tem alguns momentos algum
tipo de protocolo mas se fizer sentido
né porque muitas vezes a gente faz
determinadas coisas sem nem se
questionar se vale a pena continuar
fazendo daquela forma né
e uma coisa muito linda também que
durante todo esse processo dessa
construção do evento
cada um é trouxe uma potencialidade
muito forte dentro de si
cada um do grupo na então às vezes nem
tudo como eu disse para vocês foram
flores então teve momentos que a gente
sentia fragilizada a itu nadando nada né
que a gente não acredita no do nada eu
chegava alguém uma música com um abraço
com o carinho naquele momento sabe então
a gente realmente sentiu toda essa
fraternidade que a gente queria passar
na construção de tudo isso eu não sei se
quer falar um pouquinho do da quantidade
de oficinas dos valores mensais e um
evento ele foi todo construído de forma
voluntária am com muitas pessoas
engajadas a gente teve festival de arte
a gente teve facilitadores a gente teve
mais de 15 oficinas de desenvolvimento
integral ea gente tinha um desafio para
levar essa equipe porque a gente não fez
em porto alegre isso que seria mais
fácil a gente resolveu fazer em canela
então o desafio de levar todas as
equipes é e aí a rede foi se estendendo
é essa energia a inspirá-lo do chão e
ela começou a
a agir por conta própria cidade de
canela a comunidade começou a abrir as
suas portas
os nossos voluntários foram todos
acolhidos com hospedagem solidária
restaurantes doaram refeições a foi algo
que realmente saiu do evento e partiu
para além de a gente fala isso porque
isso é tudo uma expressão da compaixão é
uma expressão do amor é uma expressão do
acolhimento que isso tudo é paz
então se de alguma forma a cada um
conseguir dar a sua parcela a partir do
seu interno do estar em paz com as suas
emoções
ele vai conseguir 10 pro outro né ea
gente conseguiu de alguma forma na rede
fazer esses movimentos
é o que foi muito rico aponta a gente
queria estar compartilhando isso aqui
com vocês aí uma coisa muito importante
desse evento que teve como uma intenção
muito forte que ele não fosse um evento
que inspirasse né mas que ele trouxesse
a manifestação ou seja as pessoas que
estavam ali todas elas de alguma forma
já manifestavam não eram só teórico
falando de uma grande idéia
lá eles faziam realmente já na vida
deles no cotidiano deles nos projetos
deles muita coisa
alinhada com essa educação consciente
com essa transformação que a gente quer
ver no mundo e a e outra outra dinâmica
que teve também foi o proac um café que
foram projetos que foram elaborados
pelos participantes estão os
participantes puderam trazer um sonho
deles ea partir do sonho deles a gente
ajudou a estrutural o projeto e esses
projetos vão ser acompanhados a gente
vai ter é inclusive o também uma uma
rede de educação que tem uma plataforma
que vai auxiliar a a colocar esses
projetos organizar eles e e também
voluntariamente a gente conseguiu
pessoas que se engajaram que vão dar o
acompanhamento para que esses projetos
possam ter sequência para que eles não
ou na praia né porque a gente está junto
e se a gente está junto a gente pode
apoiar em que a gente tem de melhor né
a gente pode incentivar a gente pode
dizer os
há os passos que a gente já trilhou e
que já se abriram e assim a gente vai se
apoiando mutuamente vai acontecendo
então o evento ele foi digamos um motivo
pra te faça rede mas a rede pela paz ela
segue e ela segue com muitos projetos
inspiradores na ela tem muita muito
retorno positivo também desse evento de
pessoas como por exemplo o cacique andré
que foi o índio que esteve com a gente
nos honrando lá com a sua presença um
central e que ele tinha um grande sonho
de botar o projeto dele no papel que era
ter uma escola para a tribo dele uma
escola de prática então ali ele disse
assim é muito obrigada na gratidão por
você de alguma forma conseguir
materializar que ela no papel e poder
deixar o que eu possa estar aqui junto
construindo isso junto então foi muito
lindo assim cada vivência em cada olhar
os seguranças vieram conversar com a
gente dizer assim eu tô emocionado eu
acho que eu nunca tinha participado de
um evento assim as pessoas que montaram
o evento também disseram olha que
diferente esse evento eu me senti parte
realmente porque vocês deixaram
construir juntos e se deixar ou da
opinião não chegava simplesmente dizendo
a coloque as cadeiras aqui façam isso
montem ali não era todo mundo parte do
processo então isso foi muito lindo
muito verdadeiro muito genuíno porque
aconteceu né e parte de um grupo que
tinha intenção então a intenção é sempre
algo que a gente coloca muito namorado
que é fundamental para qualquer coisa né
que a gente tem uma intenção clara
alinhada e vontade confiança fluxo no
universo se joga joga se une que ninguém
está sozinho e é isso a gente está
repetindo repetindo repetindo porque a
gente tem que repetir repetir a gente
realmente z é isso mesmo é possível
saber precisar perceber que esse real
hoje
tem tantas coisas maravilhosas sakineh
nos dizendo
novo 1 é possível que ele já tá aí que a
gente olha para o lado e enxerga ele só
que pra isso a gente também tem que
cuidar um pouco da nossa freqüência am
vibracional da nossa energia a gente tem
que ter com a nossa freqüência
energética alinhada buscar sempre trazer
isso também por nosso cotidiano perceber
como é que também a recuperação né
como é que eu estou me sentindo eu estou
viva propulsão ando tem vida que dentro
de mim ainda né a gente tem que trazer
esse âmbito propês o al e na verdade o
nosso recado
nossa nosso compartilhar a esse né a
gente escolhe o fluxo da corrente que a
gente vai pegar a gente pode se sentir
sozinho a gente pode se sentir
desamparado
a gente pode se sentir incapaz mas nesse
mesmo mundo em que a gente vive isso a
gente pode escolher um outro fluxo da
corrente desse mar da vida que nos leva
da escassez para a abundância que nos
leva para o amor que nos leva para a
colaboração que nos leva para a
construção e um exemplo de tudo que a
gente escolhe a gente cria nossa
realidade
a gente cria nossa realidade ea gente
coqueria juntos porque nós não somos
separados
nós somos partes do todo nós somos a
parte da terra nós somos uma célula da
terra em ação e é só fazer nossa parte
ea nossa parte não é fazer muito além do
que ser pacífico com a gente mesmo do
que a gente ter aceitado que a gente se
amado que a gente se acolher no momento
que fazer isso contigo tu tá fazendo com
o outro transborda tu transborda por
outro aquilo que tu é então a gente de
alguma forma na rede a gente conseguiu
viver isso muito claramente isso nos deu
uma certeza é de que um novo mundo é
possível que um novo mundo então é
possível e esse novo mundo de paz começa
comigo comigo com você
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]